Shure: 听过吗啊
Shure: Have you heard it?
Alice:听过
Alice: Yes, I've heard it.
Katrina: 真没听过
Katrina: I really haven't heard it.
Katrina: 听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Tasha:谁没听过
Tasha: Who hasn't heard it?
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard it.
Shure: 完了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, haha.
Lucia:真没听过哈哈
Lucia: I really haven't heard it, haha.
Alice:好像听过又好像没听过呢
Alice: It seems like I've heard it, but also not really.
Shure: 朴树的
Shure: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 这首就比较欢快
Shure: This one is more upbeat.
Jake:挺好这
Jake: This is nice.
Shure: 这是备选一
Shure: This is option one.
Jake:对备选可以
Jake: Yeah, this can be an option.
Katrina: 备选二是什么
Katrina: What's option two?
Katrina: 备选二是开心超人
Katrina: Option two is Happy Superhero.
Shure: 开心超人
Shure: Happy Superman
Shure: 大家小时候看过吗
Shure: Did you watch it when you were kids?
Shure: 完了你这
Shure: Oh man, you...
Shure: 明显跟我们有点代沟啊哈哈
Shure: It's obvious we have a bit of a generation gap here, haha.
Alice:开心往前飞
Alice: Happy flying forward
Katrina: 对对对就是这首歌
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, that's the song.
Jake:然后还有这是个动画片吗
Jake: So, is this a cartoon?
Shure: 对动画片
Shure: Yeah, it's a cartoon.
Jake:我确实也不知道
Jake: I really don't know it.
Lucia:那行咱俩没代沟哈哈哈
Lucia: Well, at least we don't have a generation gap, haha.
Jake:这这这长什么样啊
Jake: What does it look like?
Jake:里边的角色
Jake: The characters inside.
Shure: 就是那个红色的
Shure: It's that red one.
Shure: 那个叫开心超人
Shure: It's called Happy Superman.
Jake:你认识这些这些玩意吗
Jake: Do you know these things?
Lucia:哦我见过
Lucia: Oh, I've seen it.
Jake:完了还是有带差
Jake: So there's still a gap.
Lucia:但我没但我没看过
Lucia: But I haven't watched it.
Lucia:应该我见都没见过我见过
Lucia: I think I've never seen it, but I've seen it.
Jake:你知道这玩意吗
Jake: Do you know this thing?
Jake:你也不知道
Jake: You don't know either.
Jake:这个人
Jake: This person...
Jake:哦水平还是比我高的
Jake: Oh, they're better than me.
Shure: 那还有下一首是这个
Shure: Okay, the next song is this one.
Katrina: 你跳舞吗
Katrina: Do you dance?
Katrina: 不会吧
Katrina: Probably not, right?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 别猜哈
Shure: Don't guess, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这确实有点疑惑了
Jake: This is really confusing.
Katrina: 有点疑惑了
Katrina: It's a bit confusing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈好
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Jake:我这个虽然没听过但是很好唱的感觉
Jake: Even though I haven't heard this, it feels easy to sing.
Shure: 对很好唱
Shure: Yeah, it's easy to sing.
Katrina: 三选一当开头
Katrina: Start with one of the three.
Katrina: 三选一
Katrina: One of the three.
Shure: 咱们听过最多的就是那个
Shure: The one we've heard the most is that one.
Lucia: 难忘今宵
Lucia: An Unforgettable Night.
Katrina: 难忘今宵在最后的我们
Katrina: An Unforgettable Night is the last one for us.
Jake:开场难忘今宵
Jake: We'll start with "Unforgettable Tonight"
Katrina: 开开开场要选
Katrina: For the opening, we need to choose
Jake:结束
Jake: Done
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome everyone
Lucia: 我投票给雨轩了
Lucia: I voted for Yuxuan
Lucia:难忘今宵
Lucia: "Unforgettable Tonight"
Lucia:好我一票已经送出去了
Lucia: Alright, I've cast my vote
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight"
Jake:对对好我是
Jake: Yes, yes, okay, I'm
Jake:我说开场我说开场我说开场开场对
Jake: I said the opening, I said the opening, I said the opening, yes
Katrina: 但是我们要开头这是开场的
Katrina: But we need an opening, this is for the opening
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight"
Jake:难忘今宵是我来搜索看
Jake: I'll look up "Unforgettable Tonight"
Katrina: 难忘今宵能用吉他弹吗
Katrina: Can "Unforgettable Tonight" be played on guitar?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:摇滚难忘今宵
Jake: Rock version of "Unforgettable Tonight"
Jake:可以吗啊要
Jake: Is that okay? Uh, we need to
Katrina: 那你好交给你了
Katrina: Okay, it's up to you then
Jake:行
Jake: Alright
Lucia:租个琴吧
Lucia: Let's rent a guitar
Jake:他带过来的
Jake: He brought it
Katrina: 他有
Katrina: He has it
Lucia: 哦那可以
Lucia: Oh, then it's fine
Shure: 那你怎么再搬回去呢
Shure: How are you going to move it back?
Shure: 能卖出去吗
Shure: Can you sell it?
Lucia:你是垫钢琴还是垫键盘了啊
Lucia: Are you using a piano or a keyboard?
Lucia:哎那我也可以试试
Lucia: Hey, I can try it too
Jake:就三个选项吗
Jake: Only three options?
Katrina: 开场的就三选一
Katrina: For the opening, just three choices
Katrina: 三选一都已经选不出来了
Katrina: Can't even choose from three
Lucia:你说竟然没有琴房
Lucia: You said there's no piano room?
Lucia:好可怜啊拍拍
Lucia: So sad, pat pat
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright
Lucia:在沙河
Lucia: In Shahe
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 公用什么
Katrina: Public something?
Katrina: 就一个公用钢琴
Katrina: Just one public piano
Alice:沙河那个校区吗
Alice: The Shahe campus?
Lucia:还在沙河
Lucia: Still in Shahe.
Shure: 哎我他妈手机去哪去了
Shure: Hey, where the hell did my phone go?
Katrina: 你自己选
Katrina: You choose.
Lucia:哦这样子
Katrina: 你选呗要不你哪个熟练就选哪个
Katrina: You pick, or just choose whichever you're familiar with.
Lucia:我还以为我们学校琴房要付钱
Lucia: I thought we had to pay for the piano rooms at our school.
Jake:彩链纸
Jake: Colored paper chains.
Lucia:已经很不可思议了呢
Lucia: It's already quite amazing.
Shure: 那就
Shure: Then...
Shure: new boy吧大家感觉听的是听过得最多的
Shure: How about "new boy"? It seems like everyone has heard it the most.
Jake:我们不用付钱
Jake: We don't have to pay.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there isn't any.
Lucia:你说你说嗯你说
Lucia: You say it, you say it, yeah, you say it.
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Jake:不是
Lucia:啊 好吧好吧对对对
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 就来这首new boy好不好
Shure: Let's go with this "new boy", okay?
Katrina: 行牛boy
Katrina: Okay, "new boy".
Jake:因为没有对
Jake: Because there isn't any, right.
Lucia:我以为你说在哪不用付钱
Lucia: I thought you meant we don't have to pay somewhere.
Jake:没有我以为你说你在说牛boy
Jake: No, I thought you were talking about "new boy".
Shure: 好 记住了吗
Shure: Okay, remember it?
Tasha:new boy是怎么唱
Tasha: How do you sing "new boy"?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Lucia:啥
Lucia: What?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New boy".
Tasha:哪一首
Tasha: Which one?
Shure: 就是这时的我看见到处是阳光是吧
Shure: It's the one that goes "at this moment, I see sunshine everywhere", right?
Lucia:哪一首
Lucia: Which one?
Alice:哪首
Alice: Which song?
Alice:啊这个听过
Alice: Oh, I've heard this one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 行那就这个
Katrina: Okay, let's go with this.
Shure: 那就这个了
Shure: Then it's settled.
Shure: 大家回去多加练习
Shure: Everyone, practice more when you go back.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: Haven't heard it.
Alice:是什么这个要开场
Alice: What is this? This is for the opening?
Tasha:开场对
Tasha: Yeah, for the opening.
Shure: 对开场
Shure: Yeah, for the opening.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Katrina: 但是我们几个人一起唱
Katrina: But we all sing together.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 跑调没关系
Katrina: It's okay if we're off-key.
Alice:好 好
Alice: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 也没什么人看
Katrina: Not many people are watching anyway.
Shure: 说唱也行你就突然来呦
Shure: Rapping works too, just jump in suddenly.
Shure: 就这样也可以
Shure: That works too.
Lucia:好你说lou那一段这是艰巨任务
Lucia: Okay, you handle the "lou" part, it's a tough task.
Lucia:交给你了
Lucia: It's up to you.
Katrina: 然后中
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 我们本来定的是两首
Katrina: We initially planned for two songs.
Katrina: 一手开场欢快一点
Katrina: One upbeat for the opening.
Katrina: 一手中间那种配合晚上那种悠闲
Katrina: And one for the middle, more laid-back for the evening.
Katrina: emo一点的那个
Katrina: A bit more emo.
Katrina: 选的是perfect和唯一二选一
Katrina: We chose between "Perfect" and "The Only One".
Katrina: 哎黄老板
Katrina: Hey Nicous.
Shure: 你这个一定听过了吧
Shure: You've definitely heard this one, right?
Shure: 混欧美圈的啊
Shure: You're into Western music circles.
Lucia:啊哪个
Lucia: Huh, which one?
Katrina: 黄老板的perfect
Katrina: Nicous' "Perfect".
Shure: 黄老板的perfect啊
Shure: Nicous' "Perfect", yeah.
Lucia:听过但我这个听的不多
Lucia: I've heard it, but not much.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Lucia:黄老板听的最多的应该shape of you
Lucia: The one I listen to the most is "Shape of You".
Lucia:哈哈口水干了
Lucia: Haha, my mouth is dry.
Alice:哎呀我妈呀哈哈
Alice: Oh my gosh, haha.
Lucia:嗯嗯
Lucia: Mmm hmm.
Katrina: 好像唯一不适合合唱
Katrina: Seems like "The Only One" isn't suitable for group singing.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那我们要不
Shure: So how about we...
Shure: 你给大家solo一个女团舞吧
Shure: You do a solo girl group dance for everyone.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:没有
Alice: No way.
Katrina: 我要跳也要拉着你
Katrina: If I dance, I'm dragging you along.
Jake:你要啊
Jake: You want to?
Tasha:你要不来一段吧
Tasha: You should do a bit.
Tasha:哈哈哈你好合适啊
Tasha: Haha, you'd be perfect.
Shure: 我不行的
Shure: I can't do it.
Shure: 我害羞
Shure: I'm shy.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god!
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 那就订perfect
Katrina: Then let's set it to perfect.
Jake:你跳一个
Jake: You do a jump.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect.
Jake:然后以后就是
Jake: And then later on...
Katrina: 中间一一下
Katrina: Just a little in the middle.
Alice:中间的不用合唱吧
Alice: We don't need to sing in the middle, right?
Jake:以后这种计算机视觉的会议啊
Jake: In future computer vision conferences...
Katrina: 可以合唱啊
Katrina: We can sing.
Jake:就会邀请你
Jake: They'll invite you.
Alice:可以合
Alice: We can sing.
Katrina: 要不然就我俩
Katrina: Otherwise, just the two of us.
Katrina: 我俩会笑场
Katrina: We'll laugh on stage.
Shure: 我就可以当学术蝗虫了是吧
Shure: So I can just be an academic parasite, right?
Jake:不是就是会邀请你就去演出
Jake: No, they'll just invite you to perform.
Jake:当就是你知道那个妮娜
Jake: Like, you know, Nina...
Shure: 妮娜是
Shure: Who's Nina?
Jake:就是信号处里的那个那个女的啊
Jake: The woman from the signal department.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这种顶级会议都会邀请他去
Jake: And top conferences will always invite her.
Jake:然后这个
Jake: And then...
Shure: 那这样
Shure: So...
Shure: 以后就顶级会议都会邀请我去是吗
Shure: In the future, top conferences will always invite me, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:真的没有
Jake: Not really.
Shure: 每每次会给报差旅并且
Shure: Will they cover travel expenses every time?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 部分劳务
Shure: Some labor fees?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这个说是说土灵奖得主请你上台
Jake: And then they'll say, "Turing Award winner, please come on stage."
Jake:哇哇
Jake: Wow, wow.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 所以我手机去哪了
Shure: So where's my phone?
Jake:所以你要不要跳
Jake: So, do you want to jump?
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Shure: 我不要我不要
Shure: No, I don't want to.
Shure: 哈哈哈你不要给我画这些饼
Shure: Hahaha, stop giving me these false promises.
Lucia:跳跳跳你跳
Lucia: Jump, jump, you jump.
Lucia:我站你第二排
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row for you.
Lucia:就是你在我前面
Lucia: That means you're in front of me.
Lucia:我站你第二排给你伴舞
Lucia: I'll be in the second row dancing for you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia:实际上那天徐璐正开始跳
Lucia: Actually, that day, Xu Lu just started dancing.
Katrina: 是我偷偷的从排后面下去了
Katrina: I quietly slipped out from the back row.
Katrina: 是吧哈哈
Katrina: Right? Haha
Alice:我们一共准备三首歌吗
Alice: Are we preparing three songs in total?
Shure: 两两首难忘今宵
Shure: Two, two songs, "Unforgettable Tonight".
Katrina: 难忘今宵
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight".
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 唱吗
Katrina: Singing it?
Shure: 拿音响放吧
Shure: Just play it on the speakers.
Katrina: 拿音响放
Katrina: Play it on the speakers.
Katrina: 然后我们就合一合
Katrina: Then we'll just sing along together.
Katrina: 难忘今宵你先一边收拾碟子一边
Katrina: For "Unforgettable Tonight", you clean the dishes while...
Jake:按出来啥了
Jake: What did you press?
Shure: 哦f和弦
Shure: Oh, an F chord.
Shure: 行那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle on that.
Shure: 第二首的话
Shure: For the second song...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hmm...
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Shure: 不是这个不是
Shure: Not this one, no.
Shure: 这个perfect大家没听过吧
Shure: Has everyone heard "Perfect"?
Jake:听过
Jake: Yes.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Jake:唱个太多的新歌
Jake: Too many new songs.
Jake:新歌新歌
Jake: New songs, new songs.
Jake:不行老歌吧
Jake: No, let's do an old song.
Shure: 这个大家听过吧
Shure: Everyone knows this one, right?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 大家都听过什么比较舒缓一点的歌
Shure: What slow songs does everyone know?
Lucia:第二首竟然要舒缓一点的
Lucia: The second song has to be a bit slower.
Shure: 对一人报一首
Shure: Yes, everyone suggest one song.
Alice:想不起来
Alice: I can't think of any.
Shure: 舒缓的
Shure: A slow one.
Shure: 我教大家唱我们乐队的原创歌曲吧
Shure: I'll teach everyone to sing an original song by our band.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 哎那耳熟能详一点的那种
Katrina: Hey, something more familiar.
Jake:草与虫之歌
Jake: Song of Grass and Bugs.
Katrina: 那种周杰伦的那种弹唱呗
Katrina: Something like Jay Chou's songs.
Lucia:搞笑
Lucia: Funny.
Lucia:周杰伦的舒缓一些
Lucia: Jay Chou's more soothing ones.
Katrina: 安静然后再叫安静
Katrina: Quiet, then call it Quiet again.
Shure: 晴天
Shure: Sunny Day.
Jake:一谋哥
Jake: One Moge.
Shure: 晴天大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard Sunny Day?
Katrina: 谁没听过呀
Katrina: Who hasn't?
Shure: 那不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, let's go with this one.
Shure: 我搜一下晴天
Shure: I'll search for Sunny Day.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 在晚上唱晴天
Katrina: Singing Sunny Day at night.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:那就唱夜曲吧
Alice: Then let's sing Nocturne.
Tasha:晚上唱夜曲
Tasha: Nocturne at night.
Jake:晚上唱夜曲
Jake: Nocturne at night.
Alice:晚上唱夜曲
Alice: Nocturne at night.
Katrina: 睛天
Katrina: Sunny Day.
Shure: 好像卡住了
Shure: Seems to be stuck.
Shure: 啊我知道来吧
Shure: Ah, I know, let's go.
Shure: OK就是这个样子
Shure: OK, just like this.
Katrina: 你哼一下
Katrina: Hum a bit.
Katrina: 到哪了
Katrina: Where are we?
Katrina: 行那就这首
Katrina: Alright, this one then.
Jake:好好
Jake: Good, good.
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Katrina: 简单
Katrina: Simple.
Katrina: :定了
Shure: 我们定完了
Shure: We've decided.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 到时候收尾就是你钢琴独奏一下
Katrina: Then you'll end with a piano solo.
Tasha:英文歌
Tasha: English song.
Shure: 新加坡新加坡国语普及率很高
Shure: In Singapore, Mandarin is widely spoken.
Lucia:可以可以我支持
Lucia: Sure, sure, I support it.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 再自由组合呗
Katrina: Let's mix and match freely.
Katrina: 想想
Katrina: Think about it.
Katrina: 想唱的或者想弹的就自由组合呗
Katrina: Sing or play whatever you want, mix and match freely.
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: This is it.
Katrina: 就是放在晚上的那个环节
Katrina: It's the evening segment.
Katrina: 就是吃完晚饭那个环节
Katrina: It's the segment after dinner.
Katrina: 也可以邀请别人他们一起
Katrina: You can invite others to join too.
Alice:哎嘉宾到晚上几点结束啊
Alice: Hey, until what time do the guests stay in the evening?
Katrina: 8点
Katrina: 8 o'clock.
Alice:8点
Alice: 8 o'clock.
Alice:他们吃饭吗
Alice: Do they eat?
Alice:需要吃的吧
Alice: They need to eat, right?
Katrina: 就是不是说点披萨吗
Katrina: Didn't we say we'd order pizza?
Alice:晚上嗯
Alice: In the evening, yeah.
Jake:傍晚吧对
Jake: Probably in the evening.
Tasha:傍晚达美乐
Tasha: Evening, Domino's.
Jake:对对对超级大披萨
Jake: Yeah, yeah, the huge pizza.
Shure: 秋吧蘸点披萨
Shure: Autumn, dip some pizza.
Shure: 有那个超级大披
Shure: There's that huge pizza.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 你练习吧
Shure: You practice.
Shure: 我觉得你们的讨论
Shure: I think your discussion
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 已经有有了一个结果
Shure: has already reached a conclusion.
Lucia:好难夹
Lucia: So hard to grab.
Shure: 嗯那我们
Shure: Hmm, then we
Jake:那我们最后干嘛呢
Jake: Then what do we do at the end?
Jake:最后一天干嘛来着
Jake: What do we do on the last day?
Jake:先唱这三首歌
Jake: Sing these three songs first.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Shure: 先唱两首
Shure: Sing two songs first.
Shure: 然后最后放难忘今宵
Shure: Then play "Unforgettable Tonight" at the end.
Shure: 就是散场的时候放难忘今宵
Shure: Play "Unforgettable Tonight" when the event ends.
Jake:好然后先唱两首歌啊
Jake: Alright, sing two songs first.
Katrina: 其实如果有自己想唱的就到时候
Katrina: Actually, if there's a song you want to sing, then at that time...
Katrina: 反正连伴奏嘛
Katrina: Just use the accompaniment.
Katrina: 连全民k歌伴奏
Katrina: Use the karaoke app accompaniment.
Jake:对  对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 然后自己自己练就行
Katrina: Then just practice yourself.
Jake:嗯先唱两首歌
Jake: Hmm, sing two songs first.
Jake:然后室友问答是吗
Jake: Then is there a roommate Q&A?
Alice:卡拉自助是呗
Alice: Karaoke self-service, right?
Katrina: 卡拉自助晚上没有问答
Katrina: Karaoke self-service, no Q&A in the evening.
Katrina: 问答是下午那天定的
Katrina: The Q&A session is scheduled for the afternoon.
Jake:对那那个内容是
Jake: Yes, and the content is...
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 知识问答
Katrina: Knowledge Q&A.
Katrina: 对明天准备一下
Katrina: Right, we need to prepare for tomorrow.
Shure: 对明天准备一下
Shure: Yes, prepare for tomorrow.
Katrina: QQ给我们出一个
Katrina: QQ will give us one.
Lucia:写一下到楼上写一下
Lucia: Write it down, go upstairs and write it down.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 然后大家记得通知自己的嘉宾
Shure: And everyone remember to inform your guests.
Shure: 就是带一点闲置的二手物品
Shure: To bring some idle second-hand items.
Shure: 来进行拍卖
Shure: For auction.
Shure: 交换好吧
Shure: To exchange, okay?
Katrina: 这个闲置二手物品是交换给谁
Katrina: Who are these idle second-hand items being exchanged with?
Katrina: 交换给我们
Katrina: Exchanging with us?
Katrina: 还是他们
Katrina: Or them?
Katrina: 交换就是拍卖吧
Katrina: Exchange means auction, right?
Shure: 就是谁谁都可以来买
Shure: Anyone can come to buy.
Shure: 就是比如说好的
Shure: For example, okay.
Shure: 我现在拍卖这个
Shure: Now I'm auctioning this.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure: 我珍藏多年的酱香型白酒
Shure: My aged soy-sauce flavored liquor.
Shure: 嗯自
Shure: Since...
Shure: 打我爷爷那年
Shure: My grandpa's time.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 对我这是做了一个违背祖宗的决定
Shure: Yes, I'm making a decision that goes against my ancestors.
Shure: 今天把这瓶酒拍卖给大家了
Shure: Today, I'm auctioning this bottle to everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后我觉得这瓶酒的起拍价是
Shure: And I think the starting bid for this bottle is...
Alice:两块
Alice: Two bucks.
Shure: 两个一钩一钩币
Shure: Two coins, one hook coin.
Shure: 好吧我们就叫一钩币
Shure: Okay, we'll call it a hook coin.
Jake:好一钩币可以一个coin
Jake: Okay, one hook coin, one coin.
Tasha:一个coin一钩
Tasha: One coin, one hook.
Jake:很虚拟啊这个
Jake: This is very virtual.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 我们把每个那个小币都上链吧
Shure: Let's put each little coin on the chain.
Shure: 给他哈哈哈
Shure: For him, hahaha.
Shure: 都想说哈哈
Shure: Everyone wants to say hahaha.
Lucia:多少数啊
Lucia:可以把它注一下
Lucia: Can you note that down?
Shure: 一勾臂
Shure: A hook arm
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Jake:对对对好
Jake: Yes, yes, okay
Shure: 可以那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle it then
Shure: 好
Shure: Good
Shure: 然后明天商量一下具体的细则
Shure: Then we'll discuss the specific details tomorrow
Shure: 就是
Shure: Right
Shure: 复现一下
Shure: Let's go over it again
Shure: 我们
Shure: We
Jake:再捋一遍那个时间线啊
Jake: Let's review the timeline again
Katrina: 三点啊 2点半到3点是
Katrina: Three o'clock, 2:30 to 3:00 is
Alice:嘉宾入场
Alice: Guest entry
Katrina: 嘉宾入场
Katrina: Guest entry
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yeah
Tasha:呦
Tasha: Yo
Jake:2点半到3点
Jake: 2:30 to 3:00
Jake:对嘉宾入场
Jake: Yes, guest entry
Jake:3点开始
Jake: Starts at 3:00
Jake:赚钱是吧
Jake: Making money, right?
Katrina: 对赚钱
Katrina: Yes, making money
Katrina: 是自我介绍嘛
Katrina: It's self-introductions, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 对自我介绍
Shure: Yes, self-introductions
Jake:班饼开始自我介绍
Jake: Banbing starts the self-introductions
Jake:三点开始自我介绍
Jake: Self-introductions start at 3:00
Shure: 或者是讲故事
Shure: Or telling stories
Jake:呃给多少钱呢
Jake: Uh, how much are we giving?
Shure: 看我们心情给
Shure: Depends on our mood
Shure: 对就是我们作为家
Shure: Yeah, we as the judges
Jake:就我们作为评委是吧
Jake: So we as the judges, right?
Jake:评委评委
Jake: Judges, judges
Jake:我们就坐着小板凳
Jake: We'll sit on small benches
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Katrina: 那一上来就让他们自我介绍嘛
Katrina: So they introduce themselves right when they come up
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Shure: 我们先表演节目暖场
Shure: We'll perform first to warm up the audience
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 表演什么节目
Katrina: What performance?
Shure: 我们给大家唱一个
Shure: We’ll sing a song for everyone.
Shure: 哈哈哈我给大家咬个打火机
Shure: Hahaha, or I can bite a lighter for everyone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:咬个什么打火机
Alice: Bite a what? A lighter?
Katrina: 他才艺很
Katrina: He’s got a talent.
Shure: 你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: You don’t know this joke?
Shure: 没活就咬打火机吧
Shure: If there’s no act, just bite a lighter.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 你这就是
Shure: You see...
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 那天说了先干嘛来着
Katrina: What did we say we’d do first that day?
Katrina: 自我介绍前面还有一个环节
Katrina: There was a part before self-introductions.
Katrina: 我看我拍的照片
Katrina: Let me check the photos I took.
Jake:还有一个game
Jake: There’s another game.
Jake:game before party
Katrina: 先知识问答来着好像
Katrina: Wasn't it a quiz first, I think?
Shure: game before party是啥来着
Shure: What was game before the party again?
Jake:拼那个拼图吗
Jake: Is it the jigsaw puzzle?
Shure: 啊啊啊对对对
Shure: Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:那个得拼
Alice: We need to assemble that.
Tasha:那个的拼好
Tasha: It needs to be put together.
Lucia:不容易拼好
Lucia: It’s not easy to assemble.
Jake:哈哈哈很难拼哦
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard to put together!
Lucia:别打伞或者别的game
Lucia: Don’t play umbrella or any other game.
Jake:别打伞或者别的game
Jake: Don’t play umbrella or any other game.
Jake:还有就是藏东西在你们各种各地方
Jake: Also, hide stuff in different places around.
Lucia:复活节彩蛋
Lucia: Easter eggs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 那有点
Shure: That's a bit...
Shure: 哦藏币是吧
Shure: Oh, hide coins, right?
Jake:对藏币
Jake: Yeah, hide coins.
Shure: :然后这个拿拿到就归他们
Shure: Then, whoever finds them keeps them.
Jake:是藏币
Jake: Yeah, hide coins.
Shure: 对对对一些散币对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, some loose change.
Shure: 1,000 来
Shure: 1,000, let's go.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们我们撒一些币
Shure: Hahaha, we'll scatter some coins.
Shure: 简称撒币
Shure: In short, scatter coins.
Lucia:你先挖矿环节
Lucia: You start with the mining segment.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:对对行
Jake: Yes, yes, okay.
Jake:那明天我们撒就撒
Jake: Then tomorrow we just distribute it.
Jake:对明天我们当撒撒币
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we distribute the tokens.
Jake:嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Jake:明天撒撒币
Jake: Distribute the tokens tomorrow.
Shure: 明天撒撒币
Shure: Distribute the tokens tomorrow.
Jake:撒撒币啊
Jake: Distribute the tokens.
Jake:我们50个币
Jake: We have 50 tokens.
Jake:我们多少币
Jake: How many tokens do we have?
Lucia:我们多少币
Lucia: How many tokens do we have?
Lucia:150个
Lucia: 150.
Jake:150个币
Jake: 150 tokens.
Shure: 150个
Shure: 150.
Jake:撒他
Jake: Distribute them.
Shure: 流 流通
Shure: Circulate, circulate.
Tasha: 50个我
Tasha: 50 for me.
Jake:不行
Jake: No way.
Jake:哈哈哈有点太多了
Jake: Haha, that's a bit too much.
Shure: 流通有点太多
Shure: Circulating that much is too much.
Lucia:20
Lucia: 20.
Jake:撒他20个币
Jake: Distribute 20 tokens.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia:光撒的只是一部分OK
Lucia: Just distributing part of it, okay.
Jake:对撒他20个币
Jake: Yes, distribute 20 tokens.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 不能全撒
Lucia: Can't distribute them all.
Jake:不能全撒
Jake: Can't distribute them all.
Jake:对要保证金融市场事从无
Jake: Yes, we need to ensure the financial market is stable.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 我是这边记得是两点半到3点入场
Katrina: I remember it's from 2:30 to 3:00 for entry.
Katrina: 然后introduction and Q&A是3点到3:40
Katrina: And then the introduction and Q&A is from 3:00 to 3:40.
Katrina: 嗯那这个暖场游戏是啥时候呢
Katrina: So, when is the warm-up game?
Katrina: 就在2点半到3点之间
Katrina: It’s between 2:30 and 3:00.
Jake:对 2点半到三点
Jake: Yes, 2:30 to 3:00.
Tasha:暖场是什么游戏
Tasha: What’s the warm-up game?
Jake:来的人就来
Jake: Whoever comes, comes.
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Finding tokens.
Jake:对找币
Jake: Yes, find the coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find the coins.
Katrina: 然后想玩那个拼图的就玩拼图
Katrina: Then if you want to play with the puzzle, go ahead.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake:然后如果拼起来的话
Jake: And if you can complete it...
Katrina: 可以奖励
Katrina: You get a reward.
Katrina: 拼不起来的
Katrina: If you can't finish it...
Lucia:拼不起来放心吧
Lucia: Don’t worry, it won't get finished.
Alice:要不按照块拼吧
Alice: How about we do it piece by piece?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
修确：就是你拼到几个
Shure: Just count how many pieces you complete.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 那总共有几个块来着
Shure: So how many pieces are there in total?
Jake:大概几十个吧
Jake: Probably dozens.
Alice:好几十个吧
Alice: Yeah, quite a lot.
Katrina: 他们有个就圆形的拼图很难拼
Katrina: They have a circular puzzle that's really hard to solve.
Tasha:三十
Tasha: Thirty.
Jake:你们作为每拼起来的人
Jake: For those who can’t complete it...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 每
Shure: Each...
Katrina: 就是所有的动物很不规则
Katrina: All the animals are so irregular.
Jake:就就大概点评一下给个稍为
Jake: Just give a bit of a rating...
Jake:随便给点钱吧要不就
Jake: And maybe some money?
Katrina: 反正他们那天拼了一个小时
Katrina: Anyway, they spent an hour on it that day.
Shure: 每拼进去多少个
Shure: Depending on how many pieces they fit.
Shure: 然后我们给
Shure: Then we give...
Shure: 就比如说每拼进5个
Shure: Like for every 5 pieces...
Shure: 我可以给你一个
Shure: I can give you one.
Shure: 你要能拼
Shure: If you can fit...
Tasha:拼5个就给一个币啊
Tasha: Fit 5 pieces and get one coin?
Tasha:你这小抠搜
Tasha: You're so stingy.
Tasha:抠搜的
Tasha: So stingy.
Alice:你知道那个有多难吗
Alice: Do you know how hard that is?
Lucia:知道有多难吗
Lucia: Do you know how hard it is?
Alice:我都快拼瞎了
Alice: I almost went blind working on it.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 你我
Shure: You, I...
Jake:哈哈哈一个币很难挣的
Jake: Haha, earning a coin is tough.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 你这是破坏市场
Shure: You're messing up the market.
Jake:你知道现在一个
Jake: You know now a...
Tasha:你才是
Tasha:你知道现在一个矿业吗
Tasha: Do you know how much a mining operation costs now?
Tasha:真的剥削你知道吗
Tasha: It's real exploitation, you know?
Jake:一个矿业多少钱吗
Jake: Do you know how much a mining operation costs now?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 你说是big矿业吗
Lucia: Are you talking about a big mining operation?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:他说一个矿多少钱
Lucia: He said how much does a mining operation cost.
Lucia:我说是比特币吗
Lucia: I said, is it Bitcoin?
Lucia:哈哈哈这差不多吧
Lucia: Haha, it's almost the same, right?
Jake:一开始也不值钱对吧
Jake: At first, it wasn't worth much, right?
Alice:我们都快拼瞎了
Alice: We're almost blind from working so hard.
Lucia:那你真得把咱这上链上链
Lucia: Then you really need to put us on the blockchain.
Lucia:给他注成NFT算了
Lucia: Turn it into an NFT or something.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:没关系要不然就按时间吧
Alice: It's okay, otherwise, let's go by time.
Shure: 阿猫阿猫通他们都在NFT
Shure: All the cats and dogs are on NFTs.
Alice:他们嗯
Alice: Uh-huh.
Alice:不管拼成什么样
Alice: No matter how hard we try.
Shure: 元宇宙 我元你家的激发宇宙
Shure: Metaverse, let's create a universe for our family.
Alice:能坐上15分钟就给他个两三个之类的
Alice: If you can sit for 15 minutes, give him two or three of them.
Jake:什么呀什么东西
Jake: What? What is it?
Lucia:木子膏呀
Lucia: It's Mu Zi Gao.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你不知道这
Shure: You don't know about this?
Lucia:有一首歌
Lucia: There's a song.
Shure: 是的热狗的一首歌叫做NFT
Shure: Yeah, there's a song by Hotdog called NFT.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:听懂一个词
Jake: I understood one word.
Lucia: 感觉都是哔哔哔
Lucia: Feels like it's all beep beep beep.
Lucia:哈哈哈对自带消音效果
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah, it's like it comes with its own censoring.
Shure: 可以听一下这个词
Shure: You can listen to that word.
Katrina: 那就这样
Katrina: So, that's it.
Katrina: 3点哈哈哈
Katrina: 3 o'clock, hahaha.
Jake:行行行
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Katrina: 3点到3:40是他们自我介绍
Katrina: 3:00 to 3:40 is their self-introduction.
Katrina: 和我们的知识问答
Katrina: And our Q&A session.
Katrina: 然后3:40到4:20是我们host part
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20 is our host part.
Katrina: 就是我们介绍我们每个人的东西
Katrina: This is where we introduce our stuff.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 4:20到5点是他们介绍他们带来的东西
Katrina: From 4:20 to 5:00, they introduce what they brought.
Katrina: 拍卖嗯
Katrina: Auction, yeah.
Katrina: 然后5点半左右就是订的
Katrina: Then around 5:30, we have the order.
Katrina: 然后就是披萨
Katrina: And then it's pizza.
Katrina: 然后6点
Katrina: Then at 6:00,
Katrina: 6点多的时候就可以开始唱
Katrina: around 6:00 we can start singing.
Katrina: 唱歌什么的
Katrina: Singing and stuff.
Katrina: 晚上就指定了
Katrina: The evening is set.
Katrina: 唱歌好像
Katrina: For singing, I think.
Jake:对晚上没啥大吃
Jake: Yeah, no big dinner in the evening.
Katrina: 哦哦我想起来就是那个呃
Katrina: Oh, oh, I remember, it's that, uh,
Katrina: 4:20 host part结束以后最后压轴的是他们
Katrina: after the host part ends at 4:20, the finale is theirs.
Katrina: 然后就可以尝一下他的甜品嗯
Katrina: Then we can taste their desserts, yeah.
Jake:啊是我不是
Jake: Ah, it's me, isn't it?
Jake:这本来就是吗
Jake: This is originally, right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:嗑完为
Jake: After finishing,
Katrina: 早上做来得及吗
Katrina: Can we make it in the morning?
Shure: 哎不行
Shure: No, we can't.
Katrina: 3点才开始嘞
Katrina: It only starts at 3:00.
Shure: 卫多美哈哈哈哈
Shure: Haha, way too beautiful.
Lucia: 番茄沙司吗
Lucia: Ketchup?
Shure: 好利来没说
Shure: Holiland didn't say.
Shure: 卫多美可能不知道
Shure: Maybe Way Too Beautiful doesn't know.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 然后那个什么调节
Katrina: And then adjust that.
Shure: 卢锡河
Shure: Lucia.
Katrina: 今天晚上就指定了一个这个活动
Katrina: We've set this activity for tonight.
Katrina: 唱唱歌然后8点结束
Katrina: Singing, and then ending at 8:00.
Katrina: 差不多6点开
Katrina: Starting around 6:00,
Katrina: 65点半的
Katrina: or 6:15 for dinner.
Katrina: 晚饭的话可能6:15开始吧
Katrina: Dinner probably starts at 6:15.
Katrina: 6:15-8点唱歌一个多小时
Katrina: 6:15-8:00, singing for about an hour or so.
Katrina: 嗯嗯没了
Katrina: Yeah, that's it.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Sounds about right.
Shure: 行我们批一点
Shure: Okay, we'll grade it a bit.
Shure: 不要那么高
Shure: Not too high.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:咱那个barbecue是啥意思
Jake: What does that barbecue mean?
Katrina: barbeque还搞吗
Katrina: Are we still doing the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque那碳昨天剩了半天咋
Katrina: The charcoal from yesterday, what about it?
Jake:现在啥意思
Jake: What's the plan now?
Jake:要不从明天开始烧吧
Jake: How about we start grilling tomorrow?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 烧没了给
Shure: Finish grilling it then.
Katrina: 这很难找
Katrina: It's really hard to find.
Lucia: 这很难烧
Lucia: It's hard to grill.
Shure: 那个有点太困难了
Shure: That's a bit too difficult.
Jake:哈哈哈东北人
Jake: Hahaha, Northeasterners.
Shure: 是不是
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们昨天自个吃上了吧
Shure: Did we eat it ourselves yesterday?
Jake:是吃上了
Jake: We did.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:花了两个小时吃上了
Jake: Took us two hours to eat.
Jake:那如果要搞barbecue的话
Jake: So if we want to do the barbecue.
Katrina: 不是明天又得去采购吗
Katrina: Don't we need to go shopping again tomorrow?
Jake:是买点直接买点串好的之类的
Jake: Yeah, let's just buy some pre-skewered ones.
Jake:就美团嘛是吧
Jake: Just order from Meituan, right?
Lucia:要不别烤了
Lucia: Or let's not grill.
Shure: 要不直接点熟的
Shure: Or order cooked ones directly.
Jake:熟的直接烧
Jake: Cooked ones, just heat them.
Jake:对熟的然后再在烤箱上面温
Jake: Yeah, cooked ones and then warm them up in the oven.
Shure: 温着温着
Shure: Warm them up.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Lucia: 因为这个烧起来的时间
Lucia: Because grilling takes time.
Lucia:可能是三到更无穷所以就太难控制了
Lucia: It could take from three to infinite time, so it's too hard to control.
Katrina: 还有咱那个酒的那个饮料也没了
Katrina: Also, we're out of drinks for the alcohol.
Katrina: 我们那个酒的饮料啊
Katrina: Our drinks for the alcohol, they're gone.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita.
Shure: 酒yes维他
Shure: Alcohol, yes, Vita.
Katrina: 外卖吧
Katrina: Let's do delivery.
Shure: 然后哦
Shure: And then oh.
Shure: 明天那个dinner time的时候喷个香槟
Shure: Let's spray some champagne during dinner time tomorrow.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哦这回给力点哈给力点
Jake: Oh, let's make it a bit more exciting this time.
Shure: 这这回必须得优雅的
Shure: This time it has to be elegant.
Shure: 这回我就手崩坏了
Shure: This time my hand might break.
Shure: 我都得把这香槟崩出去
Shure: I have to pop this champagne.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈要么就是我手飞出去
Shure: Hahaha, or my hand might fly off.
Shure: 要么就是盖飞出去
Shure: Or the cap might fly off.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这吓人
Katrina: That's scary.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: It's gone.
Jake:没了
Jake: It's gone.
Shure: 没了
Shure: It's gone.
Shure: 要不就这样
Shure: How about we leave it like this?
Jake:就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Shure: 那休息
Shure: Let's take a break.
Alice:还有装饰房间的
Alice: And there's room decoration too.
Jake:装饰房间是
Jake: Room decoration is...
Katrina: 装饰房间
Katrina: Room decoration.
Katrina: 要给他们看吗
Katrina: Should we show it to them?
Katrina: 还是就我们自己内部看看
Katrina: Or just keep it for ourselves?
Jake:呃他给他们看
Jake: Uh, show it to them.
Jake:因为不是不是藏东西得
Jake: Because, no, it's not like we're hiding something.
Tasha: 藏到房间里
Tasha: Hide it in the room.
Jake:合适吗
Jake: Is that appropriate?
Shure: 不合适吧
Shure: Not appropriate, right?
Jake:不合适
Jake: Not appropriate.
Shure: 哈哈哈你笑什么
Shure: Hahaha, why are you laughing?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 没笑
Katrina: Not laughing.
Shure: 你仿佛看到了什么一样
Shure: You seem to have seen something.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 没看见
Katrina: Didn't see anything.
Shure: 不是你脸为什么那么红
Shure: Why is your face so red?
Shure: 你看到我什么了吗
Shure: Did you see something about me?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我脸红了吗我没喝
Katrina: Hahaha, is my face red? I didn't drink.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 那就那个环节设置在哪啊
Katrina: So, where do we set up that segment?
Jake:那个环节
Jake: That segment.
Jake:incho吧就在这
Jake: Let's set it up right here.
Jake:可能Q a之前就是暖场吧
Jake: Maybe the Q&A session will warm things up first.
Katrina: 就是两点半到三点
Katrina: Yeah, from 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:对两点半到三
Jake: Right, from 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:三点一开始先暖个场吧
Jake: Let's start warming up at 3:00.
Jake:大家转一圈
Jake: Everyone take a lap around.
Jake:然后坐坐到座位上
Jake: Then sit down in your seats.
Katrina: OK对那就
Katrina: Okay, yeah.
Jake:就是三点
Jake: So, 3:00.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:大家游戏
Jake: Everyone play some games.
Jake:就是在客厅这边
Jake: In the living room.
Jake:把币给把撒的币给找着
Jake: Find the coins that were scattered.
Jake:然后找完之后就开始开始
Jake: After finding them, we can start.
Jake:然后大家每个人带他们走一圈
Jake: Then everyone takes a lap around.
Jake:走一圈之后买东西
Jake: After the lap, buy some things.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Alright.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我们是不是
Shure: Should we...
Shure: 杨老板应该做个总体的presentation呢
Shure: Jake should give an overall presentation, right?
Jake:做做一个
Jake: Give a presentation.
Jake:做个开场呗
Jake: An opening speech.
Jake:对欢迎各位嘉宾各位领导
Jake: Yeah, welcome all the guests and leaders.
Shure: 杨老板得做一个小的小的答辩是吧
Shure: Jake needs to do a small defense, right?
Shure: 对我们为难为难他
Shure: Yeah, let's make it hard for him.
Shure: 为什么要这么做
Shure: Why do it this way?
Shure: 百度让我这么做的哈哈哈
Shure: Because Baidu told me to do it this way, haha.
Shure: 这就是我的答辩
Shure: That's my defense.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 我真的挺好答的
Shure: It's actually pretty easy to answer.
Lucia:只答不辩
Lucia: Just answer, no need to defend.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright then.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:那就收工
Jake: Let's wrap it up.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrap it up.
Shure: 关卧好
Shure: Close the room.